[Music]
looking to get your little one a tonka
truck this holiday season
well
you're gonna have some trouble and if
you want to give your spouse a
personalized ring or pendant you may
already be too late
the national retail federation sees 8.5
to 10.5
consumer shopping growth from last year
pushing forecasts to almost
860 billion dollars
but as shoppers begin spending on gifts
many aren't finding what they want
online or they're seeing bare shelves in
the stores
this year supply chain issues are
threatening to derail everything two
billion out-of-stock messages were sent
in october alone that's up 325
from the same month in 2019 according to
adobe analytics who was seeing
electronics hit the hardest followed by
jewelry apparel
home and garden and pet products
after two years of shopping disruption
it's safe to say retailers need a win
during these crucial months but it won't
come easy concerns around covet shut
down factories in vietnam this fall
which slowed down production containers
are piling up at the ports on both the
west and east coast of the u.s there are
too few drivers to shuttle the goods to
distribution centers and not enough
space in warehouses and all of this
could affect the types of gifts that you
want to get for your kid your spouse or
pet
retailers especially mom and pop shops
say that they've had trouble getting
tonka trucks puzzles teddy bears bikes
you name it and if you usually get a
christmas tree
this year both live and artificial trees
may be harder to come by jewelers are
saying better quality larger cut
diamonds may be in short supply
even florists are having a tough time
getting everything from tulips to white
roses you may even notice the supply
chain bottlenecks when walking into a
store
ever see more denim jeans than cotton
shirts things like books and dolls set
to go out on sale just in time for this
holiday season are hitting weeks-long
shipping delays
shipping delays that look like this
while retailers race against the clock
to stock shelves ahead of the holiday
season containers full of goods pile up
outside of the ports of los angeles in
long beach
in the streets of wilmington in the
outskirts of the twin ports
officials say between 150 and 200
citations are issued for misplaced
containers every week
for the folks who've already started
their holiday shopping more than half
said that a product they wanted to
purchase in a store or online
was already out of stock plus retailers
aren't looking like they're going to
offer as many discounts this season
this holiday season isn't the return to
normal that the retail industry expected
at the start of this year it has its own
set of challenges the biggest message
they're trying to tell people is
shop early to make it a merry one
[Music]